cette année fait rarissime les 193 pays
membres de l'organisation ont tenu à
participer à l'événement six jours
pendant lesquels sous les états membres
auront l'occasion de s'exprimer
la pandémie de kobe 19 sera bien entendu
au coeur des discussions
le secrétaire général antonio gutiérrez
souhaite renouveler ses voeux pour la
mise au point d'un vaccin contre la
copie de 19 et la distribution équitable
de celui ci dans le monde
un appel qui risque fort de n'être qu'un
voeu pieux
encore la semaine dernière on apprenait
qu'un petit groupe de pays riches
s'étaient déjà réservé plus de la moitié
des futurs doses de vaccin
l'épidémie il faut le dire a révélé
l'absence de solidarité entre les états
membres
en près de huit mois seul un recueil de
résolution à la pandémie a été adoptée
par l'assemblée générale sans pour
autant arriver à un consensus
les états unis et israël s'ils sont tout
simplement opposé pour ce qui est de
l'action concrète un appel de fonds de
10 3 milliards de dollars a été lancé
pour aider les pays les plus vulnérables
à ce jour il n'a recueilli qu'un quart
du financement nécessaire sur le plan
géopolitique l'agent daris que d'être
très chargée avec un dossier brûlant le
dossier iranien alors que washington
vient de décider unilatéralement de
rétablir les sanctions de l'onu à
l'encontre de téhéran
quasiment les seuls dans le monde entier
a estimé que ces sanctions sont en
vigueur les états unis menace
explicitement sous les autres pays de
sanctions si ces derniers ne se pliait
pas à leur décision
et si les états membres de l'onu ne
remplissent pas leurs obligations pour
appliquer ces sanctions les etats-unis
sont prêts à utiliser leurs propres
outils pour punir ces défaillances dans
ce contexte le discours de donald trump
mardi à l'assemblée générale de l'onu
est particulièrement attendu
côté russe vladimir poutine s'exprimera
également ce mardi et devront être
évoqué la situation en biélorussie à
propos de laquelle russes et américains
seront voix des accusations d'ingérence
sans oublier la situation au proche
orient ou encore les tensions en côte
d'ivoire à l' approche des élections
présidentielles
cette 75e session s'ouvre donc avec un
enjeu de taille pour l'organisation
internationale l'avenir du
multilatéralisme et le maintien des
équilibres mondiaux dont la crise
sanitaire a mises à nu la fragilité